NAME HIM.
- YEAH.
- YES, BUT IT'S GOT
TO BE SOMETHING HARD.
IT IS BADASS.
- YEAH, VERY BADASS.
- HELLO, "CEE LO GREEN."
- OOH, I LIKE THAT.
WHAT ABOUT "IVAN DRAGO-N,"
LIKE THE GUY WHO HAD
THE SINISTER FLATTOP?
- "REPTAR," RIGHT?
FROM RUGRATS.
THAT'S BADASS, DUDE.
- YEAH.
- THAT WAS SUCH A TOMMY MOVE
BY ME BY NAMING HIM THAT.
IT'S SO TOMMY.
- WAIT.
SHOULD I GET A FLATTOP?
- I REALLY FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS
AREN'T HEARING ME.
I CAME UP
WITH THE PERFECT NAME.
IT'S "CEE LO GREEN."
HE HAS THOSE--
THOSE SHORT, T-REX ARMS,
AND, I MEAN, HE'S A THUG.
HE WAS IN GOODIE MOB.
- SO THAT'S A "NO"
ON THE FLATTOP?
- HEY, [bleep] THE DRAGONS!
- WHAT?
- HEY, HEY, HEY!
WATCH YOUR MOUTH!
THIS IS A FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD!
- YEAH!
[bleep] YOU, DICKHEAD!
- YEAH, YOU GOT A PROBLEM
WITH REPTAR,
YOU GOT A PROBLEM WITH ME!
- DID YOU SEE THAT POSEUR
WITH THE SKATEBOARD?
[Adam laughs, Anders scoffs]
- HEY, SKATEBOARDER DUDE,
WHY DON'T YOU, UH,
FIND A REAL IDENTITY?
'CAUSE YOU'RE LYING TO YOURSELF.
- I'M A TAXPAYER!
WHAT ARE YOU?
A SAX PLAYER IN THE BAND,
YOU IDIOT?
- OH, GET 'EM.
- YEAH, PROBABLY.
THAT'S A COOL INSTRUMENT.
- NERD!
- LET'S, UH--LET'S FINISH
DRINKING SOME BEERS,
BECAUSE THE SWEETEST REVENGE
IS LIVING WELL.
DARIUS RUCKER SAID IT,
SO YOU KNOW IT'S REAL.
- I MISS DARIUS RUCKER.
- YOU'RE RIGHT.
LET'S COOL OUR GUNS.
- LOVE THAT SONG.
HE WAS IN BUSH, RIGHT?
- I THINK NOT.
- WHAT DO YOU SAY
WE FINISH THESE BEERS
AND, UH,
CELEBRATE AT THE BAR?
- I LIKE IT.
- I LIKE THAT IDEA.
DIBS ON YOUR HAIR GEL, DUDE.
- OUR DRAGON
IS GONNA SEAL THE DEAL,
CEE LO GREEN STYLE.
- YEAH, DEFINITELY.
BUT HIS NAME'S REPTAR.
- BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
CEE LO GREEN.
- DON'T MAKE ME
SWING ON YOU, BRO.
- YEAH.
- OH, YOU'RE GONNA SWING ON ME?
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
- I'LL SWING ON--
- OKAY,
EVERYONE'S A TOUGH GUY!
EVERYBODY'S A TOUGH GUY!
- SWING ON YOU, BRO.
- HOW ABOUT I SWING
RIGHT OVER THE TOP?
- KIYA! KIYA!
- WATCH IT, BRO.
I GOT THE MEANEST UPPERCUT
IN FREAKING CUCAMONGA.
- [retching]
- LET IT ALL OUT, LITTLE GUY.
OH, NICE!
GOOD DISTANCE.
GOOD WORK, BUD.
PROUD OF YOU.
DERS!
DERS, WAKE UP! WAKE UP!
- WHAT'S UP?
WE GOING TO THE BAR?
- THEY'RE ROBBING US!
- OH, MY GOD. WHAT?
- NO! CEE LO!
- I GOT TO GET A PHOTO.
I'M GONNA GET THE PLATES.
- COMING FOR YOU!
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- DERS!
- WAIT. WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- DERS, GRAB!
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- HELP! GRAB ME.
DON'T LET GO!
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- DON'T LET GO!
- I GOT YOU.
I GOT YOU. I GOT YOU.
YOU ALL RIGHT?
- REPTAR!
- I GOT A PICTURE.
- DID YOU TAKE IT FOR ME?
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
- REPTAR!
- OH, DAMN IT.
THE CAMERA WAS THE WRONG WAY.
- REPTAR!
- OH, MY GOSH.
YOU LOOK JUST LIKE THAT GUY
WHO WAS RAPING HIS KIDS
IN THE BASEMENT IN AUSTRIA.
- I KNOW. I KNOW.
IT'S THE EYEBROWS.
- [grunts]
- [sighs]
CAMERA WAS BACKWARDS.